You guys,
I'm so excited about this.
Eddie Murphy
is my guest tonight!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love Eddie so much.
In fact, earlier today,
I realized his career really
sums up what President Trump
is going through right now
I'll show you what I mean.
You see, 48 Hours ago,
Trump got impeached.
In fact, things got so bad
he even considered
Trading Places with Mike Pence
Yep, Trump had no idea
bribing Ukraine
would Boomerang back at him.
And now impeachment
will be a stain that follows him
for the rest of his Life.
Yeah, Trump was sending
hundreds of tweets.
People thought
that he was Delirious.
In fact, Trump was so mad,
he even considered
fleeing to Mexico, but he
couldn't make it over the wall
that's blocking everyone
from Coming to America.
You see what I'm saying?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, you guys, Christmas
is just a few days away.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, it's that
magical time of year when Da
goes through eight rolls o
Scotch tape wrapping one gift.
-Oh.
-That's right.
Christmas is almost here,
and if you really
want to have some fun,
put a giant red bow
on your neighbor's car
and then take your wife
out to see it.
[ Laughter ]
I do it every year.
[ Applause ]
This year, I saw that
Red Lobster is selling
an ugly holiday sweater
featuring a pouch
to keep your biscuits warm
While every guy is like,
"That doesn't mean what
I think it means, does it?
Oh, and I saw that this Saturday
is the first day of winter
Winter will end on March 19t
or hopefully sooner.
It all depends on if
Pete Buttigieg sees his shadow
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, I saw that
Elizabeth Warren is on the cover
of this month's
"Rolling Stone" magazine.
Not to be outdone,
Bernie Sanders is on the cover
of "Kidney Stone" magazine
and...
[ Laughter ]
-Really?
-Good article.
-Wow!
-Guys, it's the end of the year,
and people are already
thinking about their
New Year's resolutions, and that
includes people in Washington.
We actually got ahold
of some of them.
And they're pretty interesting
I'll show you what I mean.
For example, here's
Congressman Matt Gaetz.
His New Year's resolution
is to...
"continue my secret side job a
the mascot for the Patriots.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Next up, here is Jerry Nadler.
His New Year's resolution
is to...
"wear my pants lower
so my nipples
stop chafing on my belt."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
And finally,
here's Bernie Sanders.
His New Year's resolution
is to "stop combing my hai
by sticking a soup spoon
into a light socket."
-Wow.
-[ Imitating
being electrocuted ]
-Finally, everyone, this i
our last show of the decade.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for being here.
Which means it's time to revisit
the funniest moment
of the past ten years.
That's right.
I'm talking about when Lou Dobbs
tried to say the name
of a Mexican city back in 2018
Please roll the clip.
-The caravan of mostly
Central American immigrant
is now in the Mexican city
of "Guaclehdahh" tonight.